you
we are ready to go for the addison
tournament 31 players a small group for
this one regular chess it's so simple
once you have played crazy house so much
less to consider just allow your pawns
to be doubled huh they're right you're
gonna give me the bishop pair let's
challenge the Queen maybe get at the
apon council Queen side maybe what's
that about
okay let's go here a half-open file look
for a knight reposition mm-hmm okay
tough to crack break down okay I'm gonna
try to play against I shouldn't have
taken my Brook off of that file trap the
Bishop Bishop b3 okay that's a weak pawn
now still looking to trap the bishop I
got him got that bishop he is short on
squares doing good on time took the F
pawn down with them take twice on B Wow
you see they just moved I didn't realize
that realized that okay
it's just double where is the main
mm-hmm they resigned factor tournament
ah he's really focused on that game I'm
not sure still going through a little
bit of an adjustment from a crazy house
okay so much less to consider all right
the Iron Giant let's see what the Iron
Giant throws at us let's go right after
the king right after him okay
well they push my night away with d5
let's just continue to develop scoop
that guy up in time okay they didn't
okay they're uncounseled no that was a
mouse slip v6 Bishop to a6
let's secure my queen post for the
moment sensitive square and b5
very sneaky that was a very sneaky move
okay let's get on these light squares
they're weakened
then I could move and hit my rook okay
this must be good yeah it's definitely
good oh boy
dominoes dominoes and we're gonna jump
in here
isn't that close to mate that's me back
to tournament okay connecting those
pieces on those intersection squares
like crazy house okay
four four twos plenty of time in this
one just a few more entered since the
start
Aggies on top I don't think we've played
you know okay Eric Joe a whole pack
again two times in three games
Eric Joey this out of the corner of my
eye the latest the latest tricky night
thank you
oh let's not drop a piece huh let's not
get forked secure my night I have some
weaknesses near their King setup some
dark square control I like that my epon
kills their night I'm trying to restrict
their night with these pawn moves where
is that night going push so check I
can't take the night because the pawn is
pinned but do that come inside castle
let's do that night g3 should be pretty
painful now should it
making him think at least okay they're
giving up the exchange there I'll take
it spend the night I also just crashed
through here take on d5 look for these
active moves recapture with the Queen
night is still pinned that's block
there's no longer pinned okay I get that
Bishop out I thought about running with
my king to age seven to a 7
Queen trade I'll take the Queen's first
activity looking for me let's get a rip
trade in no longer looking for me let's
grab him grab that pawn he's important
defend him give a check take there and
then hunt down this guy clock is not
good
Oh No Oh
don't know time ah man oh that was so
bad man alright I have to kick it into a
higher gear enough of that you can't
lose on time like that that was such a
good position okay here you go
reboot reboot recover there you go
let's open it up go right after the king
focus on the light squares d3 is where
you want to be now let's do this okay go
inside castle take this guy Bishop c5
I'm on the Brooke mmm let's go all the
way back let's hang on to him
hmm let's go here take with the bishop
maybe here was better probably
let's get back there maintain control
let's grab that pawn and another why not
well your piece is working bishop was
attacked there I had a free rook we're
doing okay on the clock it's a check and
form eight soon clean here we need three
oh really
still have
don't kind of mate happening okay let's
just back up for the moment Bishop here
let's give a check okay I got the Queen
though mate soon they resigned back
determine where are we at whoa that was
a really really quick pairing thirteen
twelve nine I'm at six
okay not open Sicilian let's just take
their get an e5 f45 I insist there we go
with tempo avoid the night exchange he
could be kicked whereas he can't be
kicked so easily maybe hit that night
some hmm going right into a pin
alright a sneaky stuff on h7 they were
all over that one they sniffed that one
right out yikes
dropping c4 at the exchange I guess uh
okay here
pile up on d7 don't like how implying
this Bishop here they still have that
move yeah not good I need a flight
square now rook up they're gonna break
with c3 maybe let's stop that idea not
looking good on the clock for me what
was wrong with grabbing that pawn can
you tell me okay Queen trade
man I feel like I could just so easily
get burned on the clock again and I feel
confident with my mouse not at all
approach with the king I already kept
pushing with this guy they took that pun
are you kidding me how dare you do that
Wow
okay back to chairman
yikes this is scary can't rely on my
mouse my best friend okay let's open it
up yeah let's throw a knight in there
mm-hmm all right if they take I get the
G file there we go
caveman chess caveman chess now just
move your queen you're gonna move your
bishop next mmm I want to crash through
an age six I'll still do it I only live
once right all right Knight you're
pushing here bishop rerouting to d3 the
pond rd D is pinned so and I got the
Queen could drop back with my rook if
they take on g1 they didn't so we have
Queen here where's the mate let's take
here mate humming Queen f5 rook g8
that'll do it I got it
he has to go
corner back to tournament 21:16 12s the
prince all right let's try to let's try
to come hard at my opponent here there
you go let's see if they play a four
there how are you gonna take B five will
it be stopped it is okay we're gonna do
something a little wild here and by wild
I mean very bad okay now no we're gonna
focus on some dark squares now for sure
for sure
let's go here yeah I don't want to
castle I like having my rook on the
h-file there in the think tank all right
we'll take anchor my 99f 492 I go g5
let's get him there hey you did it once
do it again why not
that's throw a punch set yourself up for
a fork
this wasn't a good idea Knight f4 that
makes them think some huh put the
pressure on throwing checks secure your
night position the pawn is pinned mm-hm
Queen is ready to be trapped over here
secure that runaway Wow
really thought we were gonna do is
secure that and run away let me try that
then next time I play the next
opportunity I have secured that and run
away is the plan nobly connect those
rooks they've burned a lot of time a lot
get back there Knight you are dangerous
on that square pins did not see that I
need time burners now clean here is that
what they're gonna do run run
check
just get the Queens off oh my goodness I
only had one point three seconds oh wow
oh and he was the leader - that was yeah
kind of important I think already nine
f3
let's chip away at this guy here b5
chase that night away
caveman chess caveman chess kingside
fiend keto and here we go alright now
we're gonna start drifting towards the
Kings side with our pieces there you go
I don't even want to take that rook no I
feel like this is somehow better just
developing that Knight is a pest maybe I
get them for free now I got these
squares covered by two or by two pieces
you know it's gonna be painful now that
move huh I'm gonna take the Queen and
then just move my Queen to an aggressive
Square Knight takes bishop would have
been pretty good too huh
they're not moving they resigned back
determine twenty one twenty eighteen
sixteen okay yeah you know that loss is
a dagger really because I was on streak
when in the first two and then losing
that third rather lose round one chef
masta again let's go Knight f6 alright
let's break up their center develop
pressure immediate pressure f2 hitting
the bishop let's try this cave Manish
cave Manish mmm it's here there hit the
rook and develop some more queenside
castle and then blast no we're going
here now and then here getting a te
three with check
take care ruck takes pawn dropping this
but each to stuff bishop here let's
check check
here look check night check
that's material though I'm up a rock now
I'm gonna keep the Queen's on let's get
out of there with check the night s to
block or not hitting the night it's
running mate mm-hmm Bishop here I want
my knight to be here let's give a check
that that check and then that's mate
right yes back to tournament
24:23 2018 less than 12 okay
Knight f3 let's actually go it now let's
chase that night around he's not around
to defend the Kings side now so it's
trying to take advantage of this let's
go here first develop with tempo hmm I
didn't do anything there let's just take
the night out get the move back they're
stopping me from castling but who that
would be all right Queen here stop the F
file pressure Queen h4 Queen h4 Bishop
f6 that's a check pin okay this is all
falling now let's check everything with
check paint next no matter what back
determine twenty eight twenty five
twenty eighteen ten minutes call it in
the Addison tournament okay twenty eight
twenty five twenty eighteen eighteen
everybody has a speed bump that righty
forty six players now in this one
lettuce
see Ethan let's try c3 build a Center
kick them around just a little bit F 45
f4 Knight f3 if he's not so careful
Bishop b5 could sting in-betweener
Knight has to block Levi let's just take
him castle you know let's push and then
get that night out of there okay let's
go to an aggressive spot Knight is
pretty much trapped no yeah I want to I
don't want a Queen trade but I guess if
it's gonna net me some material I was
looking for something more aggressive
I got that Bishop still okay that's the
no soup for you move no castling Forks
as well push it's pretty serious take
with the pawn keep some pieces on
connect that pond if the King moves I
queen it's improved Mike
position keep going
you're not gonna get made it it's okay
you've you've experienced crazy crazy
house chests you could do this you could
walk a fine line looking for matin - or
one that's double check mate back
determine 32 29 21 less than eight okay
uh-huh
47 players now chest prints in second
phobic third let's try c5 ok Queen b6
let's take like this I'm gonna gain a
tempo against their queen let's do this
link link that Bishop tempo against the
Queen go here take the knight and then
take the bishop if Knight c3 something
pretty natural mm-hmm
I guess we'll go here okay get that guy
out of the way let me do this and strike
at h2 huh oh boy that's me back to
tournament thirty six twenty nine twenty
five twenty less than seven seven point
lead seven minutes ago okay
Pahoa Vic okay let's try and advance
with this exchange okay light-square
control I see alright
mm-hmm all right my idea is to exchange
darts we're bishops in anchor and night
yeah take that pawn who cares who cares
about that pun I get the b2 pun look at
the positives you have no no stop that
night from being dangerous there you go
there you go now the pieces are
infiltrating just like crazy house be
crazy I'm fine with that
Queens entering play here Queen takes
pawn rook takes c6 threats rook is
restricted that's just a pawn cares who
cares Knight takes here Forks whoa
forks everywhere that's a lot of pieces
being hit and there goes the Queen back
to tournament forty thirty three twenty
five twenty twenty less than five okay
ah seven-point lead still we might get
paired up again or not the Iron Giant
let's try c5 okay how could we do
something wild
okay fine with that
there you go I have a center I have a
center now let's connect that night with
something like a bishop right here point
pieces at the King caveman
enough to let's take that play g4 I'm
gonna get my Queen to h4 this Knight is
a loose piece yeah let's go here I don't
want to take the knight let's take the
rook now and then the knight there we go
Queen check mm-hmm okay Queen here maybe
let's get another piece involved and
then I should have done this sooner
okay that's winning a lot of material
for a second there I was thinking oh I
could then use that material no you
can't Knight blocks huh okay rook g3
there is no rook f1 pile up on that
pinch piece I could have just taken the
Queen I thought they were gonna play to
f2 mmm let's try it again there we go
Rick f1 isn't defending now let's take
care work your way into a pin they had
rook to e1
where is the mate they're down on time
back determine less than three whoa whoa
whoa whoa 44 41 that guy's three back
and he might just be ready to finish
this might be for all the marbles here
is he playing right now okay let's get a
sinner here there okay here's the plan
what's up with that
Oh let's remove now let's go here I
don't know that that was a good idea
night on f4 they didn't give me the
bishop hair move forward the bishop here
I could do that double up I created a
lot of weaknesses just then a real lot
they resigned what's that about 48:41 28
I had a lot of pieces pointing at their
king but I don't know to resign like
that okay you know Scandinavian huh
let's go knight here can I get a quick
move in nice tempo I have a good lead in
development let's open stuff up you know
let's go so okay structural defect now
keep the Queen's on Knight takes c6 rook
e1 this is collapsing he six can't be
defended forks discoveries sir
eight let's take the Queen they Castle
they get mated they didn't move their
King yet did their same story if they
Castle they get made it I'm not quite
they have to pitch the rook ain't next
to me next I get it in time before the
term intends three-to-one yes I got that
in before it ended it wouldn't have
mattered who fifty to forty five fifty
to forty five twenty eight twenty eight
okay forty nine total players on this
one here's page one to hang on a moment
I always miss this up there we go page
one two three four five
sit all rights to the forty four of you
that took part in this good games all
you